30 à 40% des produits du repas en France
finissent à la poubelle heureusement des
restaurants scolaires réagissent c'est
le cas par exemple de la cantine d'Aser
sur Cher depuis plusieurs années elle
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
et tente désormais de réduire l'ensemble
de ces déchets depuis début mai il n'y a
plus de serviettes en papier les élèves
amènent leurs propres serviettes en
tissu et vous allez voir que ça se voit
dans le volume des poubelles reportage
d'Aurélie Renaud
hachis parmentier fromage et fruits
frais comme chaque jour 280 petits
écoliers déjeune ici les produits sont
locaux et cuisinés maison l'objectif
numéro un de la cantine ne rien
gaspiller
si on veut manger léger bah on prend pas
trop de trucs on prend des trucs mais
pas grand mais si on a envie de manger
gros bah tu prends des grands trucs
c'est un peu comme
un restaurant où tu choisis les aliments
que tu veux manger par exemple
aujourd'hui tu as pris seulement une
demi-pomme oui parce que j'ai pas trop
faim avec des portions adaptées les
poubelles ça Lège en moyenne les déchets
par repas et par enfant s'élève ta 150 g
ici on a atteint les 25 le déchet qui
persistait les serviettes en papier
désormais elles ne sont plus les
bienvenus au restaurant scolaire chaque
famille doit fournir une serviette en
tissu pour économiser le papier parce
que c'est avec du bois et on coupe les
arbres de la forêt ça fait 1000
serviettes par semaine qu'on jette pas
et effectivement même quand on recycle
bien bah ça a un coût donc le meilleur
déchet c'est celui qu'on fait pas pour
proposer des portions individuelles aux
enfants plus question de passer par des
aliments